[Music]  have you ever done anything bad  when i was young  i did something bad  [Music]  unforgivable  there was this  man  and he was handsome  charismatic  and he noticed me  and i guess i wasn't as tough we thought  what happened nothing  just i just feel a bit off  [Music]  go away  are you speaking of me  stay away from me and my kid okay you  are mistaking me for someone else  i know him  i know what he's capable of  i've missed you so much  the life  we made was  perfect  come after me  come after my child  i swear to god  i will kill you  [Music]  he wants to hurt us  but i won't let that happen  i think you're  having an episode  [Music]  i'm the only one that can see you  the only person that really knows  who you are  [Music]  you